it's about the passion
not the product if you want to have
success as an entrepreneur you're
thinking about launching a new business
it's always going to be more successful
if you love what you're doing
it doesn't matter what you're selling
but it matters that you
love your business it's the number one
most important rule in business
is that you love what you do if you look
at famous entrepreneurs any famous on
look at how they got started
it was because they had a deep love for
what they're doing and the people who
start a business just trying to make
money they never do
they never do they burn their money
their time the resources
going in the wrong direction because
they weren't passionate about it from
the start you have
to love what you're doing i get asked
all the time
by entrepreneurs who write into me and
they say evan i'm looking at this
product or this product
what do you think which one should i go
with doesn't matter to me
my opinion doesn't matter which one do
you love more
where can you add value that's the one
you'll be more successful with
you don't start a business just by
looking at
the market research and saying this is a
growing industry
and this is a dying industry so we
should focus on this growing industry
what's more important is which which
industry are you more passionate about
because you can have a lot more success
in a dying industry that you're
passionate about
because you can reinvigorate it then a
booming industry
that you have no passion in you too many
people just jump into this because they
think hey i can make a lot of money and
they never do
so you have to follow your passion this
comes as a result
of a question i got from one of my
newsletter readers love you guys
irene who wrote in the say evan i'm
interested in starting an online
business but unsure what products i
should feature
here's what i'm looking at jewelry kid
stuff outdoor high-end jewelry
electronics larger ladies wear what
advice do you have for me
and this is a common question i get
asked all the time
it doesn't matter if you're selling
high-end jewelry
larger ladies clothing electronics
all of those make money online and they
will continue to make money online and
they can make money for you
the biggest thing is which one do you
actually care about
where is your passion live where can you
add value
where can you tell a personal story
right if you're recommending an
electronic product
why do you have a connection to it can
you tell me why this one is better than
another one
can you be a trusted expert can i like
you
know you feel like you're giving me the
truth feel like you're giving me a lot
of extra value
by explaining the products to me that's
why i'm gonna buy from you
if you're just throwing up a website
like everybody else has selling the same
products that everybody else has you're
not gonna have success
so all of those ideas can work for irene
and if you have a lot of
similar questions if you're trying to
figure out what product to sell for your
business
any product can work but you have to be
passionate about it
if you are deeply passionate about it
know that there are other people in the
world
who share that passion and who will want
to buy from you
who is going to be the leading expert
who loves this business
who bleeds this business so you can see
their passion
seep out of it that's the guy i want to
buy from
so it's always the passion not the
product
believe for those of you watching if you
have a story about how you followed your
passion
and helped that translate into a
successful business i'd love to hear
from you please leave a comment below
your story can also help inspire other
people who are watching and reading so
please share your story you like this
video thumbs up below
click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much i'll see you
soon